[Applause]
alex how do you feel about reparations
oh [ __ ]
you know you can say like here's the
problem two percent of people in america
had family that was alive when black
people were slaves in america
so it becomes like a corporate thing
like get us all fight with each other
i'm for reparations for everybody when
it's all corporate tyranny
and manipulation of digits and things so
here's the deal if we could pay
reparations once
and get it done and stop racial division
i'll be all for it but
they're not trying to end racial
division they're trying to intensify
racial division
so there's unlimited money so great okay
if everybody that
has family they can prove was a slave
the united states
a million dollars i'd say it's all
digital give the money
it'll just go back to the economy but
they don't do it
it's not gonna do that because they're
not doing it
in stuff they're doing to keep the
problem going so there's unlimited money
[ __ ] i mean we can build here's the
thing about humans
you think we just build aircraft
carriers nuclear reactors we can do
anything now
yeah so they want to make it about oh
what are we going to give you oh we're
this group we're going to give you
something because you got [ __ ] over
that group trying to give you something
wants to run you so i'm just saying
give everybody everything i'm telling
you it's unlimited man
humans can't do anything so this is
interesting like
what about the idea and this is why i'm
actually really sorry black people
are very conspiratorial they're and
they're biggest listeners but they
should be
waiting they're your biggest listeners
yeah overall if you look at any
demographic yeah about
a third of our audience is
african-american seriously
yeah but that makes sense to me because
if you look at like who the victims
of governments
black people right yeah like you even
brought it up i think i was listening to
you on a podcast you were talking about
the tuskegee experiment but like so
black people are very skeptical not only
of vaccines but of government in general
because they've been on the
the [ __ ] end of i'm against you being
tested on
dude whatever they do to anybody they'll
get to me yeah yeah yeah so i guess what
i'm wondering is like
the the reparations thing it what's
interesting to me is
as payback for the treatment
post-slavery
right like the red line that's almost
worse bro like you could argue that
that's
nice it didn't come from regular people
how about from goldman sachs or jpmorgan
talk to like like if they said oh bank
of england we're going to pay black
people back
i'd be all for it mm-hmm but like well
like some average dude
what if they just imagine some white
dude that like works at a restaurant
he can barely pay his bill he's got he's
divorced he's got to pay the uh
you know state this money for now he's
got to increase taxes so he could pay
back somebody else he's going to be
pissed off and he's sharing like i'm
going to give black people money that's
[ __ ]
but if you said hey ibm you ran the
nazis you're going to pay money um
i don't think that how about that i
don't think that poor guy white guy
would be upset at all they'd be like
[ __ ] on board
because of us yeah so
hit who did it tell them truffle if
people are like kid who did it
but the media's like oh we're gonna make
a whole we're gonna make some white dude
like
is a lifeguard paid money that person's
like [ __ ] this i'm trying to make them a
racist
but if you actually hit who no seriously
some dude who works at a jewelry store
or a guy that works at an auto parts
store they're like i'm white so i got to
pay some things
they're like [ __ ] that no but if you
actually hit the companies that did it
they profited off for it and that
actually increases racial division if
you do
because the white guy that's like
mechanic he's like i gotta pay black
people
yeah and the lifeguard he's already
saved him he's like fixing a black
lady's car
he's here like he's [ __ ] this black
lady over here but meanwhile ibm and
bill gates and the globals did it make
them pay
that's a great idea so reparations
should be paid by the people that
profited
off of the enslavement of the black
people or they'll be on board with that
i said
[Laughter]
i'm serious like i don't give a [ __ ]
about these people
now that piece of [ __ ] i'm just saying
like i want everybody to be successful
man
or have the opportunity to be successful
yeah one more question
so you i was all in dude yeah because
i've gotten a little bit of a sense of
you're very charismatic and um you
you seem like you just want people to be
positive and you don't like to see
racial divide and [ __ ] like that but a
lot of your audience is
very conservative and some are like
they can come across as racist like do
you ever
speak out like against your audience
that is about that
because well you're right i don't see
that no not when you're reaching
hundreds of millions of people
yeah you're gonna have bad people yeah
but i mean that is very here's what i
learned
as soon as you try to stop what they're
doing it gives them power
it's like i'm promoting freedom so it's
as soon as i i want the left and with
the detractors and with the races
so there's the races there's detractors
there's the media and then there's other
there's all these groups yeah as soon as
you like
go hey i want to fix stuff i want to do
an assessment they go oh my god you do
this and then
it's all bs so as soon as you try to
like say here i'm doing that
they just attack you don't know how to
describe it it's like a
because i don't i mean obviously we're
going to kill each other we keep doing
this
the planet's going to blow up it's a
little bit planned and so you ask that
question it's a really good question
but i don't even think about who the
groups are or who their names are
um it's just it's just bigger than
everybody man
how convinced yeah
you